[Music]
Angie was smiling with daughter Zahara
in New York just hours before she filed
a 17-page doc leveling explosive claims
about their Infamous airplane fight in
2016. quote Pitt choked one of the
children and struck another in the face
he poured beer and red wine on them and
outside the plane door pit again
physically abused one of their kids Brad
was cleared of any wrongdoing but this
is the first time Angeline has been on
the record not named as Jane Doe the new
allegations come from Angie's 250
million dollar Chateau mirval
countersuit against Brad so why include
them in her War over their Winery well a
source close to Pitt weighed in with E.T
claiming it's to get additional
attention she continues to rehash revise
and reimagine her description of an
event that happened six years ago we
talked to Pitt about his kids in August
I love them to find their own way find
their own voice and flourish another
star split Tia Mori forgive him you
forgive yourself I I think that's the
key she's ending her 14-year marriage to
actor Corey Hardrick due to
irreconcilable differences ETS obtained
the docs they have a prenup and Tia's
asking to terminate spousal support to
her ex and for joint custody of their
kids cree and Cairo she's only four
years old she motivates me to make the
right decisions no matter what those
decisions are whether they're in
relationships she's an extension of who
I am Tia was just with E.T last week and
talk about timing yesterday when the
divorce news broke her twin and Sister
Sister co-star Tamara released a memoir
I support her the more he's have her
back she just kind of just wants to
process it all take it all in and you
know be a little private about that I do
have a lot to say it's just when am I
gonna say it
[Music]